Hello everyone, this is Frank Defradus, and I'd like to welcome you to another week of HoloTalk for the week of December 20th, 1999.
And this will be the final HoloTalk show of this year.
Uh, we will return once again after the new year.
Uh probably, let me see if I can find my calendar here.
Uh looks like uh probably will be January 9th, the week of January 9th, 2000.
So I'd like to take this opportunity that if you happen to uh celebrate uh this holiday season to wish you a happy holiday and hope that you'll come back and tune in to more Holo Talk shows uh for the uh year 2000.
I've got a number of guests lined up uh for interviews on the shows as well.
And to start off, I'd like to thank many of the listeners who offered to send in past HoloTalk shows from this year from um fall on.
I had them in a folder on hard drive and I didn't have them backed up like I have the other Holo Talk shows backed up.
And you know how it goes.
I grabbed that folder, took it down to the trash for some reason, and emptied that trash and bye-bye HoloTalk shows for the entire season so far.
But thanks to a number of HoloTalk listeners, I think we're pretty close to having the entire season rebuilt.
In fact, one Holo Talk listener just went ahead and put them all on discs and shipped them to me, which was very nice.
So thank you very much.
Um I will give an update right after the new year just in case one or two of them are still missing, and uh we'll let you know if uh any additional shows are needed to fill that up.
And what I'll do over the holiday is go on to the archive page and get all of the shows back up on the archive page so that you can listen to not only the shows from two years ago or last year, but uh all of the shows from this season so far as well.
Moving on, a few news items.
Um this is more general interest, I guess, than news, but uh Bill Pugh, who is the uh teacher who uh had a hand in rewriting the new state standards for communication technologies in the state of Florida, uh having holography written into that for next school year, uh came up to Allentown to visit the studio and uh do some work, and we took a few of his laser pointers and his laser diodes and put them on the table.
He was having uh difficulty giving getting images uh and we wanted to test to see what the trouble was.
So among the a number of other things that he was up here for as well.
So we uh took the laser diodes and I set up an interferometer and I found something very, very interesting.
And uh he had an infinitor, which is what Steve Michael and I have been using for uh quite some time to create the laser diode holograms or laser pointer holograms, and uh that showed a real nice uh pattern of uh fringes.
Uh not very stable.
I mean, there were times when it was stable, but every so often it would sort of like uh throw a little bit of a fit and the fringes would move or they'd go away or do this and that, and it happened every so often, you know, the fringes would come back in and seemed really nice, and then it would happen again that you know they'd start to drift.
But you know for 1499, that's certainly to be expected.
What was really interesting is he o also ordered a few other laser pointers or laser diodes, however you want to term them.
Uh one of them was for a gun sight on a gun.
Obviously that's why it's called a gun sight, uh for a handheld gun.
And he said he was not able to ever get a successful hologram using this gun sight.
So, you know, I reviewed the material and it looked like a very nice uh setup.
Um had a 635 nanometer diode uh colonnading lens and provided a beautiful beam.
I mean, this beam looked cleaner than any helium neon laser beam I've uh ever seen come out of a tube.
And uh very sharp and uh uh very nice looking beam, which you would think that this would be able to create holograms, but I put it on the interferometer, and would you believe we could not even get fringes?
Nothing.
It was that bad.
He also had a I guess you would call it a module.
It was uh the laser diode in housing, and it also had the chip sticking out of the back of the laser diode housing with two pigtail wires coming off of it that you connected your battery to.
And we put that up there as well.
Uh, I don't know if he tested, I can't really remember from the other day whether he said he tested his making holograms and wasn't successful with it or not, or whether he even used it at all.
But uh once again I put it on the interferometer, and there were fringes, but they were very light gray.
In fact, if you didn't know what to look for, you wouldn't have seen or noticed the fringes at all.
Which leads us to believe that it's not always possible to use anything when it comes to these uh diodes and diode modules to make holograms.
And you know, we're gonna have to find out what you can use and what you can't use.
If someone all of a sudden decided that they wanted to order that gun site and try to make holograms with it, they'd be completely out of luck because no matter how hard I tried, we could not even get any fringes at all with the laser light.
Now I don't know whether this has anything to do with the uh drive circuit or whether it's the diode.
I imagine the 635 nanometer diode is going to be a 635 nanometer diode.
My guess, and this is just from working with them to begin with and my guess is as good as anyone else is out there on this as far as this goes, is that uh the answer basically is in the drive circuitry.
I don't think I I think you could probably take one of those diodes and just hook it up to a more accurate power supply driver and all of a sudden you'd notice that you have fringes.
This may be true, this may not be true, but that's the feeling that I get and um it's very important if you're deciding to start with uh laser diode holography that uh you'd be very careful in what you buy.
Now we do know the infinitors work very well for fourteen ninety nine.
I think you paid a pretty hefty price for this gun site, and it turns out it's not capable of making a hologram at all.
Very interesting, but I think a lot of this has to do with the drive circuit.
And it's quite possible.
Now I know when I was reading the instructions it said that it actually had a an adjustable potentiometer on there, uh adjustable resistor, uh, where you could uh turn down the drive current.
Um I really should have turned that down a little bit and you know seen if that helped because it may be overdriving it.
Uh in order for it to be a gun site and uh cover as much distance as possible.
It uh they may actually have that uh uh variable resistor set so high that fringes fringes are are just destroyed when you put it onto a uh interferometer.
It's just it's just over driving too much.
So that that may be the problem right there, but uh who wants to go through all that trouble.
In any case, just to show him what nice fringes are like, um I set up one of the DNS laser that Sam and I designed and uh put that on the interferometer and he really almost fell out.
In fact, in fact he fell over to the point of buying one.
So uh unfortunately we're sold out of the units, but uh he's he's going to have one shipped to him right after the new year.
Okay, moving on.
Um I have an announcement here from Steve Michael, and Steve is working on a continuation of the uh shoebox holography guide that I have, and it's going to be an advanced uh booklet where you can do uh actually the title is going to be Advanced Techniques and Laser Pointer Holography.
And it's going to be built around a shoebox holography system, and uh we're looking forward to that.
In fact, he's um well, he has some things on here that I can say and some things he wants to just keep a lid on until things are together in about four weeks.
But uh he did do a master to copy.
That's an H1H2 fiber optic technique uh using the shoebox holography method of just the little vibration isolation feet and uh you know, laser pointers and things of that nature.
So uh he's going to write up these advanced techniques, put them into a little booklet and offer them on his website, and according to this email that should be available in about four weeks or so.
So you want to uh keep track of what Steve is doing uh by visiting his website at www.curiedimagery.com.
Uh his website's also listed right on the link page, the holography link page at my site if you'd like to go over there and visit.
So we'll be looking forward to seeing that book come out.
And speaking of Steve Michael, I was just on the phone with him earlier this evening.
And you know, Steve and I we've we've worked on this laser pointer thing for for quite some time.
Uh he went off uh continuing his investigation and different techniques techniques with laser pointers.
I stayed with that for a while and then moved on to uh uh working with the higher power diode laser lasers, which eventually uh led to the system that Sam and I developed from some of the uh shortcomings that I found that both of us found in the uh la the higher power laser diodes.
And uh, you know, Steve and I we don't actually see things eye to eye at times.
And we're going to put a show together where we can both come on and sort of like go back and forth a little bit on how he thinks about certain things, how I think about certain things.
Like, for instance, Steve's real big on split beam holograms.
Um I'm not.
I'm real big, and I think the future is going to be advanced uh single beam holograms.
But who knows what it's going to be, but you'll have an opportunity to come on and hear both of us talk about it and give our points and counterpoints on the air, hopefully maybe once a month, uh, where we can both get together sort of like uh Siskel and Ebert does with the movies.
We're going to do this with holography.
And there's a number of different things that Steve and I are on opposite sides of the coin with, and uh this will be a nice way for us to get together and real really wrestle it out, so to speak.
And we'll do that on the air, and you can come on and tune in and listen to those shows, and it should be a lot of fun.
Right, Steve?
All right, got an email from Dr.
Salim Valera.
And this is very interesting here.
Steve, pay attention because this is about single beam work.
Um Dr.
Valera is a research scientist at the Manchester Metropolitan University in the UK, England.
And I'd like to read what he wrote to HoloTalk that he uh uh would like to have or would like to share with the uh HoloTalk listeners.
Hi, Frank.
In your latest HoloTalk, you gave several good reasons as to why single beam holography is now preferable over split beam techniques.
As you know, small green frequency doubled and blue diode lasers are also readily available on the market.
It is only a matter of time before they become affordable to the average hobbyist.
This is opens up the possibilities of real full color holography.
The trouble with three-color transmission holograms recorded on a single emulsion is the crosstalk between the various fringes.
So if a master transmission hologram is recorded simultaneously with the red, green, and blue beams, and is then illuminated for an image plane transfer, the red beam is diffracted by the blue and green fringes as well as the red fringes, resulting in multiple images in the transfer plane.
Once the three beams have been suitably combined, the setup for full color reflection holograms is exactly the same as for the single beam monochrome setup.
Further, if an image plane hologram is required, the image can be pulled forward using the transfer technique described in your holo talk.
The brag selection of the wavelengths again prevents crosstalk.
Well, I'll tell you what, maybe uh the first show that Steve and I do where we can go back and forth, we can have it as uh single beam versus split beam.
What will happen in the future?
Points and counterpoints.
So uh tune in to that show.
I spoke with Steve earlier tonight, and uh he thought it was a good idea too.
He's up for it, he's game, so to speak, and uh we hope that when we have our first show available for you, that you'll tune in and also send us your comments on the show as well.
Well that about wraps it up, folks.
Uh this is the end of nineteen ninety-nine.
I'm not going to get into whether it's the end of the millennium or not, because some people seem to think that it is, and some people seem to think that it isn't, and this and that, but I will wish everyone a very happy holiday season, and also a very happy new year.
Of course, this is the last year of the nineteen hundreds.
I don't think anyone can argue that.
So um holography is now moving into a new age as well.
And if I've been able to do anything to help it move forward and continuing its growth, uh, I feel very honored to do so.
And I feel also feel very honored that you choose to tune in to the show each and every week as well.
I uh have a number of guests that are going to be lined up starting with the uh whole talk that we'll be uh providing the week of January 9th.
And uh I hope that you decide to come back and listen until we go until Memorial Day of the year two thousand.
So this is Frank Defrades for Hole Talk.
Thank you very much for tuning in, and I will see you after the new year.
Take care.
God willing, of course.